vous êtes prêt
êtes-vous
spock appuyez sur la gâchette
oui le capitaine
lance la séquence d'activation sur trois
deux
un
monsieur kirk se dirige vers une collision à
0,432 capitaine il y a des débris juste
devant copiez ça
whoa jim vous êtes loin du parcours je sais je
sais que je peux voir ce
don  ne bougez pas,
utilisez votre boussole d'affichage, capitaine, vous
devez corriger précisément 37,243 degrés
.  grand mr scott où es-
tu capitaine il n'arrive pas à t'entendre
je travaille pour récupérer son signal
tiens bon capitaine qu'est ce que c'est mon casque a
été touché laura dis moi que mr scott est de
retour pas encore je suis encore  travaillant sur un
signal son communicateur fonctionne je
ne sais pas pourquoi il ne répond pas qu'est
-ce que c'est que vous êtes starfleet ou
sécurité privée montrez-moi votre autre main avez-vous l'
air d'une sécurité privée
collision imminente détectée con utilisez une
action évasive il y a des débris direc  tout à l'heure je le
vois
mr sulu avons-nous perdu con je ne sais pas
commandant j'ai du mal à le
suivre et tous ces débris
sont khan touchés nous essayons de le trouver maintenant
capitaine vous devez ajuster votre
destination cible à 183 par  473 degrés
étincelle mon écran est mort je vole
aveugle
capitaine sans que votre boussole d'affichage
n'atteigne votre destination cible est mathématiquement impossible spock si je
reviens nous avons vraiment besoin de parler de votre
bannière de chevet commandant
il ne va pas y arriver
mon écran fonctionne toujours
je te vois carker 200 mètres devant moi
à 1 heure viens à ta gauche quelques
degrés et suis moi
scotty nous nous rapprochons nous avons besoin d'un
accueil chaleureux copiez
vous copiez scotty si vous nous entendez mr
scott ouvrir  la porte dans dix scotty neuf
la personne compte à rebours c'est quoi je
pense que tu entends des choses sept le
coup
mr scott ouvre la porte